what to do, baby? booze.
it's your favorite.
blam! o cyst bake!
and it is that time of the year again
where the support groups for the blind imaging pair
groups that I created back in 2021
are now open.
so if you don't know what I'm talking about,
back in 2021,
I posted a video here on TIKTOK
asking if there was anyone that was blind
or visually impaired
that would like to be a part of a support group.
from that video,
I created several different groups.
um, the group for the guys and ladies and moms.
this year will Mark
2 years that the groups have been going.
we typically will open the group
to allow people to come in,
and they would close a group down
just so we can allow the new people to get to know
the people who have been there for a little bit longer.
and once we feel like, um,
there's been enough time
and enough bonds have been formed,
then we open the groups back up again.
and right now
they're being opened.
all these groups are so,
so, so special to me.
they have helped me become a better person.
I have achieved so much in the past almost 2 years
because of these groups.
I've done things that I never thought I would do.
I've gone places I never thought I would have gone
with these individuals.
and just overall,
I found real,
genuine friendships in these groups.
and these people are like my family.
there have been so many people that have come and gone
in the groups,
but there are so,
so many people that are still there today.
and because of these people,
I feel very,
very comfortable now opening groups up to more people
who are looking for a place,
looking for support,
looking for real,
genuine friendships.
um, and you can find that here in these groups.
we take these friendships and bonds so very serious
because we share a lot of our lives with each other.
we know each other's kids,
we know each other's family members,
we know each other's fur babies.
like, we are so invested into each other,
and we want to be able to allow that for more people to
have and share as well.
we have been there for each other on their birthdays,
on occasions,
holiday occasions,
holiday parties,
Halloween parties,
Christmas parties,
movie nights,
game nights.
we have been there
for people who are having trouble in their lives,
people who have lost people,
people that are losing their homes.
like, we are just there for each other when we need them
or when we need each other,
at our good days and our bad days.
so if you are blind and vision pair
and you have wanted to be in part of these groups,
now is your chance.
my admins will be down in the comments contacting you,
so please be on the lookout.
in your inboxes for messages from one of my admins,
um, comment down below.
information about yourself,
like your name, your age,
your eye condition,
if you're a mom,
if you're a parent,
um, and anything else you just wants to know about you,
and one person from my admin team will reach out to you,
and they will find the perfect spot for you.
I am truly, truly grateful for every single person
that I've ever met from these groups,
and I'm truly grateful for everybody that is
still in the groups.
the friendships I've made,
the bonds I've made,
meeting in person,
creating memories, just.
just spending time and being there for one another,
they have truly changed my life,
and I want that to be able to be shared with others.
so. oh, sorry,
moving around.
so if this is something that you want for yourself,
please comment down below,
and like I said,
someone will reach out to you shortly.
thank you. love you guys.